[Musique]
bonsoir sivan ravive merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors
comment réagit-on cette annonce de
reconfirme en israël sachant évidemment
qu'on est en pleine fête dans le pays
la situation a empiré au cours des
dernières semaines depuis l'été nous
nous dirigions effectivement vers un
confinement de trois semaines ce qui ne
plaît pas du tout aux israéliens il ya
beaucoup de frustration
les gens voulaient revenir à la vie
normale ce qui était le cas au cours de
l'été et la situation l'effort ça à
revenir chez eux à se confiner chez eux
à reprendre à un mode de vie extrêmement
aller force à éviter les synagogues
pendant les fêtes religieuses pour ce
confinement qui va commencer vendredi 18
septembre qui est également le modèle en
juif c'est vraiment la grande fête juive
dans le monde et ensuite jours plus tard
ce sera le yom kippour c'est une période
très importante de célébration
religieuse pour les juifs et ses règles
ses règlementations forcément les
citoyens à rester chez eux à éviter les
synagogues en tout cas quelques
personnes seulement pourront se
rassembler en même temps il n'y aura pas
de célébration avec la famille étendue
écrit non cela bien sûr des conséquences
économiques les commerces
fermeront tourisme intérieur va être
étouffé les écoles seront fermées les
restaurants également l'épicière donc il
y aura vraiment des fermetures très
étendu ce qui ne plaît pas aux
israéliens
certains comprennent qu'un sur
l'importance et les avantages en matière
de santé mais beaucoup critiquent
fortement le gouvernement
comment justement on explique dans
l'état hébreu cette recrudescence du
virus c'est l'un des pires records après
bahreïn en termes de contamination
comment explique-t-on israël avait
plutôt bien géré cette crise
sauf erreur de ma part jusqu'à présent
on peut étudier la situation selon deux
points de vue tout d'abord israël a été
l'un des premiers pays à mettre en place
un pont finement on a fermé les
frontières on a interdit les visites
d'étrangers et le confinement à
fonctionner à l'époque on s'est retrouvé
avec à un nombre de cas par jour 2 0 et
donc la vie est revenue au mode
ordinaire mais on va pas certaines
personnes pensent que la vie est
redevenue normale un peu trop rapidement
les israéliens agissent et comme si rien
n'était arrivé et certaines personnes ne
respectait pas tout les rêves ne portait
pas correctement leurs masques ne
respectez pas tout à fait la
distanciation physique
c'est une raison et l'autre raison c'est
le nombre de tests
il y a quelques mois en israël on a
testé quelques milliers de personnes par
jour aujourd'hui beaucoup plus on parle
de 40 me teste par jour donc bien sûr
cela signifie qu on enregistre plus de
cas confirmés
donc cela pourrait également expliquer
en partie la situation aujourd'hui en
tant qu'observatrice
est ce que cette situation sanitaire en
israël justifie mesure aussi strict
quelle est la situation à ce que vous
avez des hôpitaux qui sont engorgés
comme on a pu le voir dans les pays
européens ce qui a justifié
d'ailleurs le confinement je disais
quelle est la situation sanitaire en
israël est ce que les hôpitaux par
exemple sont sont engorgés la situation
a très certainement empiré bay
auparavant on avait quelques centaines
de jours de cas par jour est maintenant
l'un voit de plus en plus jusqu'à 4000
cas par jour la situation empire dont de
façon exponentielle
nous n'avons pas encore de pénurie de
matériel de ventilateurs mais le
problème se pose pour une personnel
médical
ils pourraient être submergées c'est
biaisé et ne plus être en mesure de
gérer la situation le nombre de cas et
le nombre de patients au jour le jour
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle
effectivement on essaye de ralentir
l'épidémie avec le confinement merci
beaucoup sylvaner aviv journée c'est
indépendant d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france